we are back and now we're gonna keep
talking captain america the winter
soldier but this time we're talking
spoilers so if you either haven't seen
the movie or if you care please go away
if you've seen the movie already or if
you don't care stick around see what we
got
well let's talk um shield effectively
gets dismantled
by the end of this thing that's that
seems like a pretty
pretty major shock wave to sort of
reverberate throughout the rest of the
world well and i i think like so if you
sort of think about like one of the
really cool things that marvel did up to
this point right was that the linchpin
holding all these movies together was
either agent coulson or nick fury right
and so shield was the sort of
centralizing force that kept all of this
together and now that's gone
right and so what is going to be like
they're going to have to work a little
harder they can't just show us agent
coulson showing up with a briefcase you
know and saying something you know yeah
you've got to work together now because
there's right this crisis
yeah and i i think what they have to be
really careful on this is um because
because they do they do a false death
with nick fury and he comes back but
he's obviously still got work to do he
talks about there's other branches of
hydra that need to be dealt with cool so
he's going to be working under the radar
but if if he just starts building
shield all over again right from the
ground up then then it then it won't
have much
use um on the other they haven't
they've never really seriously talked
about doing this but it does leave
marvel in an interesting place
if they were to do a nick fury solo
movie right uh
the character essentially he's no longer
locked into the the sh the helicarrier
bridge now he's got a lot more mobility
where he can do his own solo type
adventure as more of a a deep level
espionage sort of
cloak and dagger clandestine spy i am
starting to get slightly cautious though
of of the lack of a body count for the
marvel universe overall because now
we've had either false deaths or deaths
and returns
for
bucky agent coulson and nick fury i i'm
kind of getting the point like the next
person that we kill right needs to stay
dead otherwise it's going to become just
like the comics where death has no
meaning and you just go okay how long
before they bring him back
well
robert downey jr has only got one more
movie on his contract and he's filming
it right now so
this is true but they're not iron man
they're not going to kill iron man
they're going to recap they're going to
james bond they're going to recast iron
man i don't know if i want james bond to
play iron man
robert redford i love the fact that he
did not turn out to be somebody else
because there were a million rumors that
he was going to end up like being the
red skull that was actually the way so i
was i was expecting that because i had
heard that spoiler that his character
was the redskins i'd heard that too and
it actually it it aligned with a
prediction that i made months ago online
because there was actually a an avengers
comic book written about a decade ago
um called the red scare where the
secretary of defense ended up being the
red skull in disguise i was waiting for
that i was a little disappointed that i
didn't see it but
also slightly happy that i didn't see it
because
that would have that would have been one
reveal too many it would have been one
revealed too many and for me the reason
i'm glad they didn't do it is it it
sells the the idea of hydra almost as an
infection it's not hydra is not about
the red skull the red skull can be gone
but the ideas and the insidiousness of
this organization will continue to
spread even without the red skull's
presence that and this this doesn't sell
the mystique of hydra that you cut off
one head two more tickets yes it was a
different head it wasn't the red skull
that came back it was a different um
having said all that the return of
arnhem zola
that was that was enough that was
because we talked about this last time
that yeah would marvel wouldn't do
something that silly about the cyborg
body but they gave you enough right of
that visual economy they gave you the
camera they gave you the big head they
didn't put it on a robot but you know
what that was pretty awesome yeah that
was as he's falling out of the out of
the helicarrier towards the water
the theater was dead silent
right you could have heard a pin drop in
that theater and the reason
that it was so quiet had nothing to do
with us being afraid for caps life right
what the reason people were so quiet was
the emotional punch that we had just
taken in the gut because we wanted bucky
to remember
so badly we wanted that connection
because there he is cap's in front of
him cap cares right cap's gonna he gives
them the line right yeah i'm with you
what was that i'm living with you to the
end right
and
and bucky doesn't he doesn't remember
he's in caps falling out of the water
like bucky doesn't remember like this is
that he was supposed to remember and
save him and he doesn't right in that
moment and
i was like that's
that is delivering on an emotional
promise you know made in the film but
for me the most important moment in that
movie um was and this was one of the
things i thought was missing um from the
avengers
was the moment where the agent working
at his terminal
decides to not enter the launch codes
right yes and for me i was like this
this is the moment
that sort of encapsulates what captain
america is about right he makes the
people around him better well i mean
that's that's that's sort of captain
america's
um not
traditional superpower is his ability to
in inspire and to bring out the best in
other people in that moment that guy has
this
whoever you know like holding a gun to
his head he's just a dude that runs a
terminal right he has no power right he
has nothing
the only thing he can do is say no he
can't really fight back
and cap has inspired him to the point
where he says
no i'm not gonna do it. and like yes
that's that's it that's it that's who
captain america is um one more
sort of under the radar character was
shield agent 13. um the blonde woman who
was posing as the nurse who just happens
to live next to steve rogers she
eventually reveals that she was a shield
agent hired by fury to kind of keep tabs
on him
um
her she is name dropped as sharon in
this com in this movie in the comics she
is sharon carter
actually a descendant of peggy carter
and
she has a long-standing relationship
they love affair with captain america
they didn't pursue that in this movie
they might in the future i
if they pursue an actual romance between
them i think
they
i don't think it works for her to be the
granddaughter of penny you know
they didn't drop a last name so they're
not locked into right there's a there's
a little bit too much of weirdness that
they'd have to suspend a display wait a
minute you're dating the great
granddaughter of the woman that you
loved and
okay i believe that you got frozen for
70 years but now you're just entering a
weird creature yeah
so i i hope that doesn't yeah but my
grandmother used to like um
um oh so um
the mid credits
secrets yes yep
now i i'm assuming that you recognize
those
thomas crutchman plays um
baron von strucker who is one of the
heads of hydra
um
did a very good job i like the monocle
look to kind of give him that class yep
um of course nobody's going to care
about him nobody's going to no no no
what everyone's going to be talking
about they're going to be focused on the
twins in their little cages quicksilver
and
scarlet witch um
look really cool yeah i mean interesting
look for um
for quicksilver um a little bit more
scruffy a little bit yeah also just i
i've always seen him depicted as sort of
a little sort of a thin little guy and
this guy feel he looks a little bigger
he's a little bulkier um but the the
issue i had with it was that he one of
the things i mean from what i've seen of
quicksilver is that the way he's been
portrayed
there's this sort of confidence um or
cockiness or to him right
with self-assertiveness and this
character
at least from the few glimpses we've had
there's a harried-ness there's a
like
a distraught sort of
which if if they're slaves or captives
or like lab specimens that might have
something to do with it well that's the
thing it looks like at least when we get
to the start of age of ultron these guys
are going to be unleashed as a weapon
against the avengers right um
yeah or or at least that that seems to
be
the the intention of the bad guys how
that'll pan out i mean right who knows
but i'll be
i'll be curious to see how
how they're going to be used because
they're obviously joss whedon thought
they were important enough to
get into a minor scuffle with fox over
who actually has the rights to these
guys right
so i mean
i think i think vital enough to the plot
that right they were willing to go there
right and part of that was i know joss
whedon said when he was doing one of the
the rounds um on one of the late night
shows he said that part of the reason he
really wanted these characters was
because with all the heroes in the
avengers most of them came down to
a lot of punching and heavy hitting type
of powers for iron man and the hulk and
to a smaller extent captain america all
seem to have super strength as their
primary part yeah power set he wanted
something visually different he wanted
the telekinesis or the kind of chaos
magic of the scarlet witch and the super
speed of quicksilver so he he really
liked them
for one thing just because they offered
a different power set that we haven't
seen in these movies and
um
like i was kind of happy to see a
speedster on film yeah dc um and um he's
getting a tv show i know he's getting a
tv show but
fundamental character of that universe
right so um i think given the and much
to paul's the like given the name drop
that stephen strange got in this one as
a potential threat to hydra it sounds
like they know who he is yeah it sounds
like he's not just a doctor yeah he's
not just a surgeon
they've got to be aware of what he i
mean maybe he hasn't started really
delving into it yet but i would think
when we get our doctor strange movie
which at at this point seems like a very
safe bet yeah yeah i've already got my
ticket
um but that when we get it he will
already be established and we'll
probably get flashback
of yeah before but it's the i doubt that
that is a movie that will be taken up in
the with the origin right but um i think
we've we've pretty much picked this
thing to death um
but it it's still alive and kicking so
go see it if you haven't hopefully
you've seen it if you watch this one but
um thanks so much for joining us and
thank you guys for seeing the movie with
me and sitting down and talking about it
thanks we'll do this again
i don't know
i will remember next month after noah
well after
what what's up it's spider-man or x-men
spider-man is up at the beginning of may
x-men is at the end of may well then
that's probably what we'll be dealing
with but spider-man x-men yes
we'll tackle those when we get to them
but until next time this council is
adjourned